this is the Jocko underground podcast
with Echo Charles sitting across from me
at the table of Woe here
uh so little something called
Hofstadter's law
which is a law to theory created by
Douglas hofstadter who is a Pulitzer
Prize non-fiction winning author
he's a scholar of physics and cognitive
science and he made this law and what
what kind of like about this law it's a
little bit of a joke
in a way he even named it after himself
which is kind of kind of funny like it's
it if you if you find something to
discover and other people you know
designate it
but when you're just like hey this is my
law uh
in the basically the law is that things
take a lot longer than you'd think
they're going to and so the way he
describes it is it always takes longer
than you expect even when you take into
account hofstader's law that's that's
the law itself so even when you know
it's going to take longer which is how
Standards Law it's still going to take
you longer than that so things are going
to take longer than we expect them to
take
and we have to plan for that and he
originally
he originally used this
I believe around explaining why I was
taking chess computers so long to beat
humans they kept saying oh humans are
going to be beat by the by computers and
chess you know in a year and then it was
like well not quite a year of five years
it ended up taking that you know a
couple decades before computers could
legitimately beat
humans in chess so there was some there
was like a little bit of a reference to
computer programming which which got me
into reading about another
rule which is called the 90-90 rule
which comes directly from computer
programming and it says I think you'll
appreciate this one the first 90 of code
accounts for the first 90 of development
time the remaining 10 of code accounts
for the other
90 of development time
so 90 Plus 90 is 180 so it's going to
take you 180 of time to get the thing
done
uh and what's what I found interesting
about that is
and I thought that I thought that you
would appreciate this as well this means
that big prod progress is made kind of
early
but it takes a lot of effort to continue
to improve so when we think about
lifting right you get someone in the
lifting
out of the gate they're making the gains
it's called new begins right by the way
Ruby games
and but those final touches I mean to go
from like a bench press of 135 to
250 like people can make up that pretty
quick you know because they just never
worked out you know then all of a sudden
they get to that but then when they get
to 250 it takes a while to get them to
275 and then they get to 300 and then
they get to like 315 three wheels right
three wheels all day yeah but to go from
for someone that's like that's a good
bench they go from three wheels to go to
like
340. it might take them six months maybe
even longer than that yeah so so it
applies there
you know what it's like uh also you
don't you don't really do any of your
own Like Home Building or projects do
you yeah like fixing stuff but not
building no yeah there's another thing
where like when you build your house
or you remodel your kitchen
or you add a room onto your house which
I've done all these things
that last like bit of trim and stuff
yeah so it's like it's they say like the
The Carpenter's house is never complete
because he gets once it gets lit moved
in there he's like I'm not doing that
other stuff yeah yeah
um
but this is why you know I've been
talking about lately that extreme
ownership leadership Loop of like what
you need to think about when you're
making a decision and I put time at the
top and the reason I put time at the top
is because it's the one thing we can't
really you can't manipulate you can't
control it at all now what we can
control is what we do we can control how
we can get ahead we can prepare
ourselves and be ready ahead of the
power curve
but
it's you don't have any control over
time so you got to think about it now
this is the other thing
um what you and I were just talking
about the big moves right the big moves
come in the beginning however that being
said this is Jocko's rule just kidding
but another thing to think about
is the big moves come but you actually
have to start
and probably the biggest hardest move in
any project in any Endeavor is the first
step
first
time you go to jiu jitsu is the hardest
time you'll ever go to Jitsu right the
first time you ever go to jiu jitsu is
probably going to be the hardest time
you ever have to go to jiu jitsu the
first time you go
to the gym is probably going to be the
hardest time you'll ever have to go to
the gym and maybe maybe it's like oh the
first two weeks right the all those two
weeks it's like you're getting in the
habit first time you go in the cold tub
yeah
it gets easier cold tub gets easier
I'm cold right now I went I got out of
the cold tub a couple hours ago and I'm
still cold right now yeah that's real I
turned off I I turned off the AC in our
space here because I'm freezing I
understand it is cold in here yeah it is
cold in here and I was in a cold dub and
brought my core temperature down to
whatever
um
so
these are good things to think about see
this is what's
use this example like if you go into my
house and I tell you I'm going to scare
you I'm not gonna be able to scare you
awareness yeah just awareness it makes
you so much more prepared
and makes you be able to contend with
some things so much better so by being
aware of the fact that number one the
first step is the hardest step you
should be aware of that and if you know
that you're like all right I'm gonna
have to like go harder right now I have
to put more effort because I need to go
to the gym I haven't worked out before
or my first day of fasting it's gonna be
so hard you got to know that it's gonna
be hard yeah and if you're mentally
prepared for that it's going to be
better for you
I had a really good conversation
um I think it was also a camp
I was talking to Jonathan and Anne they
have a
first in nutrition Montgomery yeah yeah
the Montgomery team
and
they were talking so they help people
with nutrition right and yeah first in
nutrition and
as we were talking
you know they they what they tell people
or one of their taglines is
you can eat anything but you can't eat
everything
which is which makes sense right so if
you really love pizza okay we can put it
on your schedule
or your plan but you know here's what
you're gonna have to sacrifice yeah
here's what you can't if you're gonna
have pizza you can't have and you and by
the way having pizza doesn't mean having
three quarters of a freaking pie right
having pizza you can have it but you're
gonna have a slice and you're only gonna
have it on Wednesdays or whatever
so you can have anything but you can't
have everything okay cool so that was
the first part but then they what what I
related to
was you know they were like you know
talking about how much you can eat of
something
and I started recognizing that the
expectations that you have play a huge
part and here's how I know this for a
fact what's your favorite dessert to eat
me yeah either a homemade chocolate chip
cookies or chocolate cake okay let's go
with chocolate chip cookies and let's
say you're eating no no we'll go with
cake so you're eating your cake sure and
I roll in
you've got a big a slice of cake right
yeah and I go bro that looks really good
can I have a bite
will you give me bite
I would give you a bite okay so and how
would you feel about you have the you've
taken two bites of your cake I roll in I
go can I have a bite you say yes how do
you feel about that
fine fine okay now check this out
you're down to your last there's one
more bite oh yeah I rolled in and I say
oh can I have that bite
you may still give it to me but how do
you feel about it yeah you don't feel
good no this has happened to me ten
thousand times in my life right ten
thousand times where people you know you
get to your last beat piece of steak or
you get to your last piece of dessert
yeah or you got one more like freaking
cookie left in the bag of those like
little cookies that are bite-sized you
know what I'm saying yeah so you what
happens is what I realized that feeling
comes from the expectation because when
there's one bite left you're excited
about having the last but you already
ate the whole freaking piece of cake
yeah but it's in your head that you got
one more bite yeah and so when I set
that expectation on you
you you got issues dude like I'm like
hey dude give me the I oh sorry when I
take that expectation from you it's
gonna hurt you yeah and it pisses you
off
so my point in saying this is from like
an eating perspective if you go oh I'm
only gonna have
one slice of pizza that's all I get and
you set that expectation
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground